hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
was like you had a realization yes
better name check out Paul on Instagram
and Twitter and she is also part of the
fan theory TV YouTube channel reactions
to Doctor Who and stuff I'm sure you
guys would love it so go check it out I
think you'll like our show come check us
out
yes that's a good promo right there
we're gonna watch this video from Screen
Rant that came out about a month and a
half ago ten animated movies where
characters actually did it I've never
personally done it so this is gonna be
especially exciting for me probably
learn something I hope I learn a thing
or two I wish there was a site where I
could just watch people doing it so I
could learn something what do you think
there you can make a lot of money off of
my back ya know if that was on the
internet most people would probably be
they're probably the most viewed thing
watch it a lot yeah unfortunately
maybe one day long mention yeah right I
do down in your and your idea do love
scenes are nothing doing movie Titanic
Fifty Shades of Grey series doesn't even
feel like pushing the boundaries anymore
okay they definitely look at cartoons
forever from Disney Classics to all
rated comedy rocks check out some
animated movies where keV
actually did it what and they trying to
save it they did it was just a
distraction from the fact that their
whole family had been banned from
Springfield for producing too much big
waves
like happens
inspired by Disney films like Cinderella
and Snow White in the Seven Dwarves
[ __ ] moves to entice his wife begin
with a montage of animals busting into
the cabinet along with singing a
romantic hum these animals proceed to a
seemingly common theme among animated
love scenes the highlight of it all is
seeing the small fan be like deer in a
little wide I just I think it can do it
less animals watch it for its father
covers his eyes from a I want to talk to
somebody
it's an animated movie for the love
scenes between a devil and Saddam
Hussein from South Park bigger Longer &
uncut would be the obvious choice in our
list but Trey Parker and Matt Stone
steamy are cool yeah it's an accountant
sorry mate he's not actually animated
puppet movie features a love scene some
graphic the MPAA originally rated an
nc-17 cut down several times I did not
know
oh no that oh my god look and I like
more and my love King probably should
have ended their production companies
trying to feed off Roger success Brad
Pitt movie cool world was released in
know about this feel like something that
belongs on moist and played by Kim
Basinger Hollywood wants to become human
she must break the biggest rule of all
in cool world no human an animation
fornication Hollywood what oh [ __ ]
I'm not saying this wish you were
wearing
while watching Hollywood puts on a full
show when they extended scene
I am dandelion cartoon characters who
want to watch the whole thing even smoke
cigarettes afterwards what is with these
cartoons trying to break free from their
queen oh damn they like actually doing
weird boxes from 1973 animated films
very quickly and even share their own
romantic musical montage romantic
montages are nothing new for Disney we
can't forget Ariel and Eric right Belle
and beast romantic dance but there are a
lot of subtle moments in the Robin Hood
montage which hint had much much more
than just mmm song playing in the
background this is one day they sing
along you don't want the kids belting
out in the next family road trip I guess
you never paid attention to the lyrics
[Music]
we blocked by the crashing stream for a
few moments but it would say the fog the
hound
the name vixen literally means female
Fox and could also be alluded to her
feisty behavior with Tom within just
abusing the berry eyelash oh yes Todd
makes the first obvious move by
presenting vixy with an important post a
quick turn towards the romantic before
things get too hot and heavy we cut away
to a couple of birds watching in from
the phone again what the watch continues
as their dark silhouettes get close
together boy did these puppies move fast
listen - voiceover and Pongo reveals
they've only been together for six
months
the look on congas face when she tells
him she's having puppies dog
while the glances but Disney kept things
pretty much clean in the 60s not
revealing too much and boy do these two
seem to hook up a lot
Perdita ends up having 101 puppies wait
which hold that by their armors well
still Perdita may not have given birth
to all 101 puppies but her and pongos
escapades did leave 215 birth puppies
still look pretty impressive number
after taking him the rest of the puppies
by the imagine weave at their house
Shrek 2 Shrek 2 begins with a honeymoon
to remember after the events of the
first Shrek Chuck and Fiona are now
married and ready to celebrate with
blitz through an opening scene montage
many parents probably wish they were
still in the PI 4 we see the green skins
couple check into a hotel room bathed
together and lay on each other at the
beach these two cannot seem to get their
hands off each other
it's okay Mary married yeah
adventures you just have to look at the
first scenes of she's pregnant no idea
for them to say
no idea everyone else to get all the
action food you never expect it once
again here's the PG shots from the movie
you're gonna have to stream this one on
your own to see all the food lovemaking
in action the crazy scene is pretty
graphic but probably isn't even the most
shocking seeing the film just hope this
doesn't take place in the grocery store
that you usually shop at that happened
to rouse I mean I didn't ask questions
about it when I was a kid I was just
like okay there's love each other I mean
she gives him duh she does come hither
it's like a real like oh I'm gonna do it
put it in yeah see ya they really did a
good call animals were always watching
them you're so true it's so true
and like I said in real life I need my
cats in there who are named after the
Fox and the ham tonic copper I don't
need my cat around when I don't know
like have them involved it's just if
they're watching it makes me feel better
and by the way I'm by myself
there's no that's worse that's actually
that makes it weirder just talking about
the movies okay what an interesting way
to start thinking about Disney's Robin
because I love that movie actually my
engagement ring it was inspired by the
flower ring that Maid Marion in that
movie so your your hubby's the Robin
Hood huh yes oh dami foxes you kinky
[ __ ] I always just thought again it was
me
- innocent yeah this video I thought it
was just a romantic interlude they were
having just they were going behind a
waterfall just because it was pretty
yeah oh you knew what was really going
on
don't let that Mormon upbringing to this
guys whatever it was sausage party is a
scene where you can literally hop to the
last 15 minutes of that movie and just
be shocked at what what you're seeing I
had a shock just from what they showed
us a lot I had heard about that scene
that they had like a full-on orgy at the
end of the movie that I watched the
movie and I'm like oh wow it's very very
shocking I can set it up for you and I
could keep I could hype this up for you
and then you will still not be prepared
just by how how insanely graphic that is
it's very graphic you should you should
definitely watch it and a fun fact about
Team America
forget their names South Park guys Trey
Parker and Matt Stone I think for Team
America they actually shot it with the
intention to go overboard and make
because it was dealing with the MPAA
ratings they knew that this scene would
get nc-17 so they intentionally shot
more extreme stuff so the MPAA would
force them to dial it back and what they
dial that back to is what they
originally wanted it to be they just
only intentionally shot extra stop just
so they can take it out yet do you think
they did it because they thought if they
had just originally presented what they
wanted it to be know what I got it deal
would be I'm like this is in 70 exactly
they were like this is better than
things approved they basically
manipulated the way because I knew
they've dealt with it and PA so many
times and they manipulate their way to
make sure they could do it that way and
just imagining what that with the puppet
it's funny a scene and I and I saw this
see as a little bit of footage of the
uncut version I didn't realize it like
you go watch the whole uncut version
somewhere but I saw a little bit of it
and this definitely uncut it's very like
oh that's very graphic stuff I'm selling
the sizzle not the whole steak here guys
hey you know a lot of this list though
was implied sex or you were reading into
what's happening like except for some of
it was was actually cool world yes
ripoff of Roger Rabbit yeah that's why
this is your channel you remembered all
their names
don't worry I'll forget it all on it
once we're done filming trivia is not my
strong suit here that scene looks like I
mean that is not implied I haven't seen
it but you know I didn't even know that
movie existed wants to be Roger
Brad Brad Pitt is probably glad that
most of us don't know it exists yeah I
think at this point I heard Angelina
Jolie had married him because she saw
that movie oh these are all facts you go
all facts I never lie I never make up
anything never never well of course not
did you know one's Lion King - she was
actually gonna have an abortion we never
make anything more edgy like in the
Simpsons I was like yeah of course they
did it of course yeah like if they have
babies like in the Dalmatians or yeah I
thought you were saying that there was a
scene in there that we totally miss for
okay they were doing it right there
actually in the Lion King
they must have actually been with Timon
and Pumbaa watching I didn't register
that that oh they must have actually
been doing it at that moment no that's
from like a biological standpoint I
don't feel like that's how two lions
have sex that's all I've seen like you
know nature videos and and other animals
in nature it's not normally you mean
your youtube search history two lions
going at it
it's okay Paula it's okay
we're all about equality here yeah and
if men are allowed to look it up so
should women just been all the time
looking up to lions this is gone down
well this is a great list video I like
the rider audited the notable I don't
know if the voiceover and the rider are
the same for this but there's some
pretty funny jokes in here so good job
Screen Rant this was a great video and
yeah hopefully you guys didn't get a
yellow dollar bill signs that the sex
thought you have in here I feel like
we've like gotten closer just by having
these conversations yeah that is not not
better for our personal lives Hey
subscribe to Screen Rant subscribed with
the real rejects check out Paula on fan
Theory TV show and hey let me for the
hell of it let me just give a patient
the day shout out here's somebody
Luke Anderson Luke Anderson does not
live in California he lives in a state
which is not coming to mind right now I
think it's Washington where he met is
the leader a manager of a bunch of FedEx
employees oh he's like the Big D's like
Tom Hanks him to be the first 20 minutes
a castaway right hopefully not the rest
of the movie yeah I'm happy why I
haven't heard from him in a while and
it's car just I'm final you are the son
of a pastor so I want to keep this very
PG yeah I don't want anything I don't
want to be inappropriate but I hope that
as a leader of a bunch of employees at
FedEx that you are able to form some
kind of reenactment of the finale of
sausage party with all your employees
part of leadership is bonding and
getting to know each other and then it
gets you to care about one another I'm
more than just a financial level or just
trying to be cutthroat about it and I'm
telling you you get that finale FedEx
where people are slipping in packages
left and right
this is really good advice you should
definitely follow up it won't get you in
I don't get a lot of people to agree
with me on these things really sound so
happy follows on board this train right
now buddy if I were to think of more
funds to deal with packages at X and sex
you'd be getting a much better shout out
unfortunately I'm crying a lot of legs
here but I love you and I hope to hear
from you soon guys we'll see you guys
later